mein Lieblingsteil eine Tombola quasi du
kannst gewinnen pass auf die Lose haben
es in sich und zwar die roten böse
Fragen und die Grünen Liebe Fragen jetzt
rat mal welches ich
nehme rosa für mich ist das ja rosa
ja darf ich jetzt aufmachen ja sonst
würde es ja auch gar keinen Sinn ergeben
ne das wä Unsinn dann muss jetzt
Vorlesen ja
und
beantworten sie hatten jahrelang eine
traumhafte Zusammenarbeit mit Reif
Schmitz warum haben Sie sich in Sachen
privater Zusammenarbeit für Kaja Jana
entschieden damals der war einfach
größer das aber nicht der Grund ne es
war einfach so ich mag Ralf Schmitz nach
wie vor auch sehr gerne und würde auch
nach wie vor mit ihm zusammenarbeiten
wenn sich das ergeben würde und wir
haben D glaube ich sehr großen Spaß aber
das ist ja nicht heißt ja nicht dass man
direkt auch privat nee also we das war
dann so das war einfach so warum sind
die Dinge so warum verliebt man sich in
jemand oder nicht oder entliebt sich das
weiß ich nicht ich glaub es kriegt nur
liegt nur an am
Geruch ja ja irgendwo stand es mal
wissenschaftlich un Sieg nur daran wie
der andere richt aber vielleicht
eigentlich auch immer ganz okay gerochen
ich nehme jetzt mal eine grüne
Frage
das sind
ja in ihren Rollen treten sie von einem
Fettnäpchen ins nächste aber im
richtigen Leben scheinen sie alles
richtig zu machen haben sie ein
Erfolgsrezept das ist im Prinzip nur D
dass man immer man selbst sein soll man
soll sich immer selber treu bleiben dann
kann man sich auch nicht verlaufen und
der Weg ist das Ziel also es ist so ein
bisschen wenn man sagt wenn man weiß od
man geht einfach mal und möchte gehen
und dann sieht man vielleicht mal rechts
weg und biegt mal ab und er ist dann
schwachsinig dann sollte man schnell you
und noch mal weiter auf dem geradeausweg
sich selbst treu bleiben das ist am
wichtigsten aber das kann ja eine floske
sein es gibt ja Leute die sind sich
selbst treu die machen aber nur Quatsch
aber im Sinne von nicht unterhaltsamen
Quatsch sondern sie gehen halt so ihren
Weg aber der ist nicht ja das ist
richtig aber man gut dass sich selbst
treu bleiben heißt ja nicht dass man
nicht auch nach links und rechts gucken
sollte und dass da auch noch andere
Leute auf diesem Weg also es ist ja
nicht so dass da es gibt zwar vielleicht
den eigenen Weg der am Ende
wird man das Unikat sein dass N diesen
Weg genau in dieser Formation gelaufen
ist nur dass auf diesem Weg natürlich
auch andere Leute gehen weil es nicht
unendlich viele Wege gibt da muss man
Rücksicht drauf nehmen beim rechts
abbiegen also vorher mal kurz gucken ob
man jemand umrennt das wäre vielleicht
noch ein wichtiges Rezept gut jetzt
nehme ich wieder muss ich eh alle lesen
oder doch wä schön ja D kann ich jetzt
auch wieder rosa nehmen ja bei uns heißt
es rot ach so rot ist ja auch logisch
rot grün helles Rot und helles
grün
die fabulösen thekenschlampen die
Mallorca Allstars und die dreisten dre
ihre Pöbelei ist wirklich nicht denhaft
sind sie im falschen Geschlecht
geboren
ja ich bin ein
äh eigentlich äh nee ich bin nicht im
Fall ich bin genau ich bin ein voll das
Mädchen ich bin halt nur mal lauter
manchmal aber eigentlich bin ich im
genau richttig also ich bin da junge
dann müss ich auch selber über mein
eigenes Glied
Lachen nein ich bin s genau richtig da
geboren es ist nur so dass es ist ja
auch oft so dass es meine Stimme macht
die ist so ein bisschen rauer und ein
bisschen tiefer und dann wird wirkt es
so ein bisschen mehr mit Druck aber
eigentlich bin ich total ich mag rosa
ich mag Hello Kitty das ist alles doch
wie ein Mädchen sch vor ich wä ein Mann
da wä ich wahrscheinlich homosexuell was
auch nicht schlimm wäre aber ja ist
deine Stimme schon immer so tief
geworden oder ist s das Folgen der
Mallorca Zeit nee es war ja tatsächlich
so dass ich in der Schule hat ich eine
sehr quäkige Stimme es gab früher das
feuerrote Spielmobil da entstand auch
mein Spitzname da gab es Ratz und Rübe
meine Mutter hat mich immer Rübe getauft
weil Rübe so eine entsetzliche Stimme
hatte und die Kinder in der Schule haben
dann irgendwann gesagt die heiß doch Mö
ja da muss die Möre heißen dadurch
entstand dann auch der Spitzname die
Stimme war immer schon ein bisschen
extremer und die ist einfach so dann
geblieben nur ein bisschen tiefer ich
bin quasi auch in einen Stimmbruch
geraten und dieses
äh ich sag mal extrovertierte ist es da
manchmal schwierig ein Freund zu
finden nee wenn es um jungen geht ist es
ja so dass ich total schüchtern bin ich
bin ja nicht ich mit der Brechstange
also auch mein mein mein Freund als ich
ih kennengelernt habe also dem hat sich
auch zähner aus also ich fand den total
toll und dann habe ich überhaupt nicht
getraut und und den anzusprechen und
beschweige den noch einen Schritt weiter
und ich bin da total verklemmt was das
angeht was so zwischenmenschliche
Beziehungen rantasten ans andere
Geschlecht bin ich glaube ich ganz ruhig
den danach erleben ihr blaues Wunder
aber dann ist ja meistens zu spät D habe
ich schon an angel aber ja gut ich nehme
noch mal grün die sind so schön die
Grünen Fragen ja
wie schaffen sie es ihre kindhafte Rolle
so seriös
rüberzubringen es hat mal ein Mensch in
einem Interview über mich gesagt was ich
ganz toll fand also über mich
geschrieben wie war das denn sie ist
ähm eine abgehalfterte Bardame in einem
teenagerkörper ich mich solche auss also
das ist ja erstmal körperlich gesehen
Kompliment und die abgehal der darb war
so eine ich weiß gar nicht ob es
abgeheift hat war ist und für mich dann
so ein dreckbild von so einer alten Frau
die also eine Frau an Bar zu stark
geschminkt die aber ja eigentlich
Psychologin ist weil die immer den
Leuten zu die sehr gut zuhören kann und
so thekenpsychologie macht und sehr viel
Lebenserfahrung hat fand ich toll aber
ist es bei mir so ich glaube das ist was
in einem drin steckt es gibt so Tage wo
man ich sage man ist immer so alt wie
man sich fühlt und es gibt Tage da komme
ich mir vor wie
14 das ist für mein Umfeld nicht immer
schön aber meistens mit sehr viel
Fröhlichkeit verbunden und das ist eben
glaube ich auch einfach authentisch
solange ich nicht versuche jünger zu
sein als ich bin weil ich bin 37 und das
finde ich nicht schlimm und die Zeichen
der Zeit nagen auch an mir aber das ist
so also ich nehme das ganz realistisch
hin also schönhits OP kä für dich nicht
in Frage für mich niemals in Frage nein
machst du denn irgendwas sag mal meine
Kolleg
die da muss ich immer also das ist ja
auch so typisch das Frau Mann Beispiel
ja da treffen wir uns in 5 Minuten wie 5
Minuten so was musst du noch machen ja
schminken ne ich ich werde ja im Beruf
sehr viel geschminkt deswegen schminke
ich mich privat ganz wenig jetzt bin ich
glaube ich auch ganz wenig geschminkt
nur und ich bin auch tatsächlich jemand
der wenn ich um 20 Uhr verabredet bin
2 Minuten von meinem Haus entfernt dann
gehe ich auch um :30 Uhr noch unter die
Dusche und bin trotzdem um 38r fertig
ich sehe nicht immer so super aus aber
das ist mir dann auch egal
ja gut ich nehme noch mal rot oh
ja ich nehme nämlich jetzt rot dann
nehme ich grün und dann abwechsel dann
habe ich am Ende eine grüne ja das ist
ein versöhnliches Ende
ja haben Sie gemerkt dass sie zu alt
sind als die jüngere Jeanine Kunze sie
bei die D dre ersetzt hat
das für eine Frage ich 3 D hat mich
also ich bin ja nicht wirklich also ich
bin ersetzt worden klar weil ich
gegangen bin also ich bin ja weil ich
bei RTL die Chance bekommen habe Angi zu
drehen ist Schan kun so viel jünger als
ich ich habe s müsste jetzt mal
nachgucken ich 3 Jahre jünger sieht man
ja gar nicht also die ist sehr nett aber
das sieht man auch noch nicht nein aber
nö ne habe ich mir gar keine Gedanken
drüber gemacht also ich war natürlich
weil 33 mein Baby war so ein bisschen
aber es war auch senderpolitik weil wenn
man bei RTL eine Sitcom dreht dreht man
nicht noch eine Sketch comomedy beiite 1
das habe ich dann auch erfahren also das
ist auch logisch obwohl für den
Zuschauer nicht logisch weil dem
Zuschauer letztendlich meiner Meinung
nach egal ist auf welchem Sender er
Leute anguckt die nett oder die er mag
und dann war das so und dann war es am
Anfang halt
eigentlich auch egal wer gekommen wäre
ich hätte immer das so beugt und gedacht
meine dre D so aber ralf war ja auch
schon ein Jahr weg oder eine Staffel weg
und das ist so alles ein bisschen
auseinandergebrochen dann und für mich
war es auch so dass 33 eigentlich zu
Ende gespielt war weil ich in der
letzten Staffel in der ich anwesend war
das Gefühl hatte jetzt langsam alle
Geschichten erzählt zu haben die ich
erzählen kann in dieser K in dieser zwei
manann eine Frau Konstellation und m
aber ich habe mir da glaub ich nie
Gedanken drüber gemacht war die ist auch
blond ich mag sie auch sehr gerne und
habe da eigentlich kein Problem mit und
dass sie jünger ist wusste ich gar nicht
dieft da ja verrückt die hat schon zwei
Kinder ne nein ja da altert man
vielleicht schneller man wei ich neh
noch schnell eine Frage eine
grünne in ihrem Buch böse Tagebücher
veröffentlichen Sie Ihre tiefsten
Gedanken und Gefühle ist das Buch als
Hilfe für pubertierende Jugendliche
angedacht ja das Buch ist ein eigentlich
alles mögliche es ist ein Ratgeber für
Männer zu begreifen warum die Frauen so
sind wie sie sind oder eben auch gerade
nicht und für Frauen ist es ein
Schmunzelbuch weil die sich wiederfinden
können sich kurz mal schämen und dann
aber denken mein Gott die anderen waren
auch so und das war aber nicht bewusst
dass es so entstanden ist und für
pubertieren da habe ich jetzt letztens
weil auch im Programm schon mal welche
sind gedacht ach wenn die mal über das
Buch lachen dann freue ich mich weil ich
habe ja auch über die Tagebücher so sehr
gelacht weil weil man so bierernst alles
war eine lebenskatastrophe wenn Markus
nicht mehr wollte oder wenn der nicht
wollte oder wenn der nicht und man muss
im Nachhinein so doll drüber lachen dass
man jetzt vielleicht den pubertierenden
die gerade denken das Leben ist ein
Schweinebacke zurufen kann Leute da
werdet ihr irgendwann euch über tot
lachen und dann ist es auch wieder okay
das ist so der Spruch den die Mutter
damals immer sagte bis Z Hochzeit ist
alles weg hat meine Mutter immer gesagt
oder wenn ich mich so ganz doof
angestellt habe hat meine Mutter immer
gesagt ja da kommst Du diese Nacht aber
mit ans liegen das es ist gar nicht
alles so schlimm nichts wird so heiß
gegessen wie es auf den Tisch kommt das
ist vielleicht würde auch zu dem Buch
passen weil die Pubertät da ist alles
emotions dann entdeckt man die Emotion
und man auf einmal Hormone weiß ich
nicht was alles pillepalle du wolltest
ja mal Prinzessin werden hast du erzählt
ja auch Königin auch Königin ja also
spießig hast du auch gesagt willst du
denn
heiraten das ist eine lustige Frage wo
ich gar nicht so
genau ich sage zu allen Themen im Leben
sag niemals nie aber es ist nicht so
dass ich jetzt sage ich muss jetzt das
ganz
dringend ich bin sehr zufrieden wie ich
bin also wie mein Leben so verläuft und
wie es auch immer weiter verlaufen wird
ich werde glaube ich to toll wenn es so
bleibt
also wenn ich meine Einstellung selber
zum Leben so bleibt werde ich immer
irgendwie zufrieden sein weil ich immer
jemand bin der sagt ach wird alles gut
und dann weiß ich nicht es gibt da jetzt
keine so genaue Planung was da noch
zugehören muss und was nicht ich bin
jemand
wenn ich im Fernseh sehen frauenehen mit
großen weißen Kleidern und und Schleiern
und die heiraten weine ich ein bisschen
weil ich ein Mädchen bin aber ich meine
auch bei der früher das ist noch nicht
so lange her da gab's mal so eine
Werbung von kraftscheiblettten
da war der Junge im Zeltlager und hat
war traurig weil er keine krafttabletten
hatte habe ich auch gefeint von daher
ist das relativ sehr relativ aber ich
gehe auch gerne auf Hochzeit ich gucke
mal also ich finde das alles schön ich
bin ein romantischer Mensch das heißt du
musst nur noch den Brautstrauß fangen
und dann könn es
passieren ich weiß nicht würde mich
interessieren ob mein Freund an dem Tag
wo ich auf der Hochzeit den
brautchrausfanger eventuell mit dem
nächsten Taxi abreist dann weiß ja
Bescheid glaube ich aber nicht nee aber
ich lass so auf mich zukommen also ich
würde jetzt nicht neö ich bin mal
gespannt was das Leben alles noch für
mich bereit hält ob dein Freund das
Interview sieht und der dann
Heiratsantrag macht nee das wäre auch
blöd das wäre schon fast wie bei K laau
nur die Liebe zählt das wollen wir nicht
na gut okay wollen sie nicht mal was
seriöses machen
nein wir
wollen ich bin total froh dass ich ich
bin weil ich eben zufrieden bin auch
zufrieden da wo ich bin
und wenn mich jemand für was seriöses
anfragt auch an dieser Stelle ein Aufruf
an die ganze Welt und das passt zu mir
dann würde ich sofort mitmachen ich bin
stark dafür meinen Beruf als großen Spaß
den ich dabei empfinde zu sehen aber
auch ganz stark dafür das als
Dienstleistung zu sehen
an den Menschen und im Moment können die
Leute sehr schön über mich lachen Gott
sei Dank und wenn ich habe auch schon
mal die Idee gehabt ich singe jetzt
französische Chansons weil man zu meiner
Stimme passt das finde aber auch nur ich
dann schön also es könnte auch schön
sich anhören für irgendwelche Jazz
Kritiker oder was weiß ich aber es
interessiert ja mein Publikum nicht ich
würde gerne versuchen weiterhin das zu
machen wo die Leute mir folgen können
und dann kommt der Punkt dazu wenn mich
ich dann jemand zu was seriösem einledt
was ich drehen könnte oder machen könnte
und es passt zu mir und ich habe da Bock
drauf und derjenige traut mir das zu
glaube ich dass die Leute auch mitkommen
weil die dann sagen ja guck mal so ich
irgendwie die Frage beantwortet ja ich
habe fand verständlich okay vi we selber
nicht mehr ob ich mal was seriöses mache
ich zieh noch mal eine grüne
Frage ich habe aber auch kein Problem
mit dem Begriff Ulknudel ist ja lustig
stell mir auch me Ulknudel optisch
gesehen sehr lustig
vor
sie wechselten von Sat 1 zu RTL und zu
Comedy Central warum reißen sich die
Sender so um sie reißen die sich M ja
offensichtlich von 3 D in Solo in Solo
das ist im Prinzip ja auch einfach nur
alles eine politikfage also dann in dem
Fall eine Medienpolitik Frage das sind
ja einfach Produktionsfirmen in
Deutschland die was produzieren man ist
einigermaßen erfolgreich und die Leute
haben Interesse mit einem zu arbeiten
dann produzieren die was und
verschiedene Produktionsfirmen Arbeiten
halt mit den verschiedenen Sendern und
so kommt das und ich bin jetzt im Moment
ein RTL Kind und bin nicht exklusiv an
den Sender gebunden also nicht
vertraglich und für trotzdem fühle ich
mich im Moment diesem Sender moralisch
verbunden das heißt wenn jetzt seit 1
käme würde ich jetzt nicht sagen ich
kann kategorisch das ausschließen aber
ich würde wenn seit ein mir ein Angebot
macht ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt
politisch ob mein Manager jetzt total
durchdh aber ich sag's mal wie es ist
würde ich das ja erstmal auch mit RTL
besprechen und sagen guck mal das und
das sind die Chancen ich würde am Ende
das habe ich von harpe gelernt immer das
machen woruf ich Lust habe auch ohne
Rücksicht auf weil das würde auch jeder
andere in dem Job machen also ist so
dass RTL sehr nett zu mir ist und ich da
sehr zufrieden bin und wenn die jemand
finden der genauso aussieht wie ich aber
lustiger ist dann bin treten die mir
auch in Hintern kann man denn einem
Sender moralisch verpflichtet sein der
ist doch eigentlich nur da um möglichst
viel Geld zu
verdienen ja man kann in so lange
jemandem also einem Sender und einer
Institution moralisch verpflichtet sein
wo man
wo wenn man solange man erkennt dass es
ganz ein Job ist und dass die daran Geld
verdienen wollen dass ich davon leben
möchte und dass ich Karriere machen
möchte und dann ist es auch okay und für
mich ist es so im Moment bieten bietet
RTL mir gute Sachen an dann macht man
die und äh
ähm die anderen lassen ja auch so ein
bisschen an die Finger von also klar
kommt auch von seit 1 kommen auch
Anfragen aber die man dann eher alle so
sagt schwierig weil man ja so ein
Haussender irgendwie hat aber es
moralisch heißt insofern ich würde
drüber sprechen bevor also ich würde
nicht einfach sagen und klanglos abhauen
sondern ich würde dann sagen Leute das
das ist mir angeboten Word das ist für
mich eine riesen Chance das würde ich
gerne machen ihr müsst das verstehen tun
sie dann nicht oder sie verstehen und
würden sagen wir bitten was noch
besseres an das ist ja im Prinzip nur
ein Deal aber inzwischen ist ja auch so
wieder die Zeiten angebrochen wo Sender
nicht Formate kaufen sondern Leute
kaufen also wenn das wür ich nie machen
also auch wenn ich bei RTL sehr
zufrieden bin also diese das sind diese
Exklusivverträge da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen oh ich hoffe nicht dass
noch irgendjemand hofft dass das
passiert und Michl morgen rausschmeißt
aber ich würde das nicht tun weil ich
finde dass man sich selber damit vom
Markt nimmt weil dann ist man exklusiv
daran gebunden und dann stellt man sich
einfach mal vor es geh ein super Angebot
von jem das kann man da nicht machen das
finde ich dumm ich finde das aber auch
für die ganze Medienwelt finde ich das
eigentlich dumm ich glaube dass dadurch
eine eine
Stagnation heißt das Wort so ja ja
glaube ich schon passt erreicht wird
also ich glaube wenn das alle tun würden
würde es stagniieren weil dann würde
stillstehen es wird keine Bewegung und
und und Bewegung ist Weiterentwicklung
Dynamik ja finde ich f ich glaube ich
dumm auch für den Sender dumm stell mal
vor die Macht irgwann nur noch Grütze
hast du dir gut der Sender kannster
rausschmeißen aber nee bin ich nicht so
ein Freund von wie aber das heißt ist
für den Sender nicht schlecht weil ich
mich eben wie gesagt ich fühle hab diese
moralische Bindung die ich selber
empfinde wie guckst du dass das was da
gemacht wird wirklich gut ist weil die
Sender sind ja heute auch in der
Zwickmühle Kosten Publikumserfolg und es
passiert ja leicht dass man in eine
Kiste reingerät wo ich sag mal die
Autoren schlecht schreiben in dem Moment
wo ich einsteige was zu tun muss ich da
Lust drauf haben muss ich sehen dass ich
man hat natürlich dadurch dass man jetzt
Jahre in dem Job arbeitet auch viele
Menschen mit denen man zusammenarbeitet
wo man weiß die liefern Qualität ab und
sucht s dann mit ins Boot zu ziehen und
m auch wenn da habe ich auch schon mit
Teilen von RTL lustige Diskussionen
gehabt sag es hat aber eine super Quote
für mich rechtfertigt Quote nicht die
Teilnahme an allen Sachen
z.B wenn der Dschungel wieder ruft habe
ich wahrscheinlich gerade was total
wichtiges vor wenn ich spülen muss ist
mir scheißegal oder ich muss eau das
sind so Sachen wo ich sag da sind auch
die Leute haben alle die Berechtigung da
re das kann jeder se da es hat eine
super Quote und trotzdem würde ich nicht
hingehen es ist ja auch wahnsinnig
privat es ist wahnsinnig privat und ich
möchte auch einfach keine kängaru Hoden
Essen ich würde am ersten Tag
rausfliegen weil ich schon beim ersten
Spiel sagen würde ne habe ich keine Lust
schmeckt mir auch nicht ich wer dafür
total schlecht geeignet ich wäre zu
aufsässig ich sehe auch nicht ein warum
was soll denn möchte ich nicht wer ich
jetzt schon aggressiv wenn ichüber
nachdenke gut soll Essen bestellen nein
was
leckeres ne super vielen Dank bittes
schön